DeMarco Morgan is in Fayetteville North  Carolina where flooding as you might  expect is a serious concern there to  DeMarco good morning good morning to you  Gail we're about 90 miles away from the  coast our elements here are drastically  different from what they are  experiencing but you said it don't be  fooled because the major threat here is  floods  yes floodwaters that's why a third is to  keeping their eyes on creeks like this  one right here behind me it also the  Cape Fear River because it's starting to  take on rain and run up you may remember  that hurricane Matthew sort of  devastated this area along with the  Lumberton when there were hundreds of  boat rescues so we can tell you this  that the shelters are filling up right  now and the nursing home residents they  have been evacuated to higher ground so  we'll keep you posted on what takes  place here in Cumberland County John all  right DeMarco thank you